jetzt sind hier irgendwelche
düsenflieger über raus man immer wenn
ich ein video drehen was ihr
irgendwelche was geht's nicht könnt ihr
immer bitte leuten jetzt was kann jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video und
zwar ist heute mittwoch ich hab mir
gedacht ich hab so einen extrem lange
keine fragen mehr beantworten
deswegen habe ich euch auf jeden fall
gefragt stellt mir doch mal ein paar
fragen was haben wir zwei reich gemacht
ich habe ein paar coole rausgesucht die
werde ich heute beantworten falls ihr
öfter mal wollte dass ich fragen mann
wurde weil das halt eigentlich auch
ziemlich cool und wichtig ist schreibt
mir die kommentare oder lassen doch nach
oben da würd mich freuen wenn ihr dann
macht und ansonsten viel spaß mit dem
video und reisen sowie vergangen mit der
ersten frage und zwar kommt von kabi xd
und sie fragt gibt es etwas in deinem
leben was heute anders gemacht ist wenn
ja was da gibt es auf jeden fall was das
hat auch so mit youtube zu tun und zwar
rege ich mich da jetzt nicht mehr ganz
so darüber auf aber halt vor einem
halben jahr habe ich mich noch drüber
aufgeregt
es war nämlich früher wirklich leichter
mit youtube ein bisschen mehr reichweite
zu bekommen ich kann mich zwar nicht
beklagen denn ich finde 60.000 ist schon
eine menge
für mich hätte ich niemals gedacht dass
das überhaupt so weit geht und ja ich
hatte aber früher mal ein channel vor
zwei jahren oder so und hat 3000
abonnenten drauf und hab dann einfach
aufgehört und es lief wirklich gerade
gut und ich weiß ich warum ich aufgehört
habe und hätte ich weiter gemacht hätte
sogar sein könnte dass ich jetzt
vielleicht noch ein stück weiter bin
aber so ist halt und ich kann es nicht
rückgängig machen aber ein bisschen doof
genau was mich auch sehr sehr viele
fragen ist bist du auf dem video der in
köln bzw in berlin also der in berlin
ist ja schon in eineinhalb monaten am
ersten und zweiten falls ihr aus der
umgebung kommt ich bin auf jeden fall in
berlin und in köln bin ich auch also
falls sie so in hamburg oder so
dann kommt nach berlin und könnte mich
da halt treffen tipps und so passte
einfach mal in die video beschreibung
falls ihr bock habt kommt auf jeden fall
rum wird mega ich freue mich das schon
richtig drauf mal wieder so voll viele
von euch auch einmal zu sehen und zeigt
dass appel x2 punkt mary oder so fragt
freust du dich wenn fans ich wieder
erkennen und sag ich mal lieber
zuschauer wenn zuschauer dich wieder
erkennen und fotos machen wollte also es
gibt natürlich situation da passt es
vielleicht nicht ganz so gut aber ich
freue mich schon immer ziemlich sehr und
ja deswegen ich lese auch in letzter
zeit immer öfter ja ich habe nicht daran
da gesehen aber ich habe mich nicht
getraut mich als übrigen deswegen
scheißegal was für eine situation ihr
könnt mich immer ansprechen es gab kein
ding
und natürlich freue ich mich darüber
auch wenn es manchmal vielleicht nicht
ganz so gut passt aber ist eigentlich
auch egal
selina heißt sie damals war falls sie wo
siehst du dich selbst in fünf jahren ja
es gibt ja in amerika schon sehr viele
youtuber die millionär geworden sind
dadurch und warum sollte das in
deutschland nicht aufgeben also ich
denke ich werde der erste davon und dann
bin ich halt voll reich und dann höre
ich auf mit nein spaß beiseite ich habe
auch keinen fall vor auch wenn es
vielleicht irgendwann mal theoretisch
möglich sein könnte bei mir youtube
hauptberuflich zu machen
es gibt zwar in deutschland schon ganz
gut jetzt den das ermöglicht wurde
aber ich will auf jeden fall was sie mir
vorgenommen wenn ich mein abi hab ich
will mich gerne mal so ein halbes jahr
bis zum jahr nur auf youtube
konzentrieren und nichts weiteres machen
aber dann halt auch studieren oder
irgendwie sowas und in fünf jahren sehe
ich mich dann halt noch als typ der
irgendwelche videos macht und damit
leute unterhalten will aber auch als
weiß ich nicht irgendwer der einen
normalen job hat sage ich mal ja sowas
fanpage blockbuster wagt freust du dich
selber fanpages dass ich finde das immer
mega kasse es menschen gibt die extra so
für mich so bilder bearbeiten und die
dann auf instagram oder wo auch immer
hochladen und ich freue mich wirklich
sehr darüber
auch wenn man sich über die ersten fünf
fanpages noch mehr gefreut als über die
die jetzt immer weiter hinzu kommen aber
ich gucke auf jeden fall immer welche
jetzt ein foto hochgeladen hat leykauf
sehr viele bilder und weil ich das mega
jet zu einfach und deswegen danke an
alle die so was machen und es freut mich
sehr und finde ich echt krass die
nächste frage kommt von jana und zwar
fragt sie wie
ziel ist die youtube hört ich würde mal
sagen man kann ich immer gleich auf
diese frage antworten es gibt natürlich
phasen da ist es jetzt nicht so wichtig
wie jetzt gerade ist mir ist und zwar
ich denke mir so ohne youtube wäre es
jetzt mega langweilig weil ich mache
wirklich so hobbymäßig macht zurzeit
nicht so viel sport also nicht im verein
oder so ich mache natürlich für mich
schon sehr viel sport aber halt nicht so
teamsport oder so und youtube ist schon
so mein größtes hobby zurzeit sag ich
mal und ich mache das wirklich gerne und
ohne youtube erteilt wie eben schon
gesagt habe ich das ebenfalls wäre auf
jeden fall viel langweiliger also ich
kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen so
ohne diese menschen die mich jetzt jede
woche gucken oder halt mal fotos leiden
kommentieren und so dass wir halt alles
ganz anders und das wäre irgendwie
scheiße und deswegen ist mir youtube
schon ziemlich viel wert es gibt sachen
die sind mir viel mehr wert aber youtube
ist mir halt schon extrem wichtig sagen
wir mal so und dann kommt auch schon zur
letzten frage und zwar hast du
eigentlich einen namen für uns ich habe
immer schon mal darüber nachgedacht aber
mir fällt irgendwie kein cooler name ein
das ist so schwer daraus was zu machen
aus alex oder was da keine ahnung falls
ihr irgendwelche coolen namen ab
schreibt die bittere kommentare dann
checke ich das mal ab und sucht den
coolsten halt raus und dann nenne ich
euch einfach so weil das ist ja echt so
dass fast jeder youtube so seine
zuschauer fans gegen den namen hyypiä
darf ja auch bock drauf deswegen macht
das uns wirklich freuen
ansonsten will ich sagen falls sich das
video gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall
noch nach oben da irgendwie es nochmal
schön instagram eingeblendet abonnieren
nicht vergessen um nichts zu verpassen
und weitere fragen einfach in die
kommentare hier auf der linken seite
geht es weiter mit meinen letzten video
das war probleme eine single samstag
kommt dann wahrscheinlich vorteil eines
denke ich mal und hier auf der anderen
seite geht es weiter mit fünf arten von
unterricht voll ist das video auch
megamäßig wollen tippt auf jeden fall ab
und ich sage bis samstag auch reindl